[Musique]
et on passe à présent dans le 7 8 à
notre page culture et on va parler pour
débuter d'un événement culturel qui mêle
la culture à la solidarité c'est la
cinquième édition de solidange je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est une soirée
avec caritative au profit du Téléthon
qui se déroule ce samedi à la Ferme du
Manet de Montigny-le-Bretonneux le
rendez-vous est donné de 19h à 1h du
matin vous avez entraperçu l'affiche de
cet événement pour en parler deux
invités que j'ai présenté également
début d'émission Daniel de salle de
l'air qui est le pilote de cette soirée
président de l'association skyden c'est
également Ceel tir qui est animateur de
la soirée pourquoi une soirée au profit
du Téléthon comment est venu l'idée
d'une telle soirée et bien le Téléthon
c'est une
œuvre caritative qui nous va très bien
parce que pour ces objectifs avec
lesquels on est en parfaite accord
d'ailleurs les résultats actuellement
qu'on a bien fait depuis
plusieurs années de travailler pour ce
Téléthon puisque les avancées notables
sont faites qui donnent
du courage aux parents de l'espoir et
une amélioration qualitative pour pour
les enfants et d'autre part aussi on est
très intéressé par la manière dont il
gère
leur association et les dons qui vont
très très très majoritairement à la
recherche je crois sur les meilleures
années vous êtes monté jusqu'à 2500
euros sur une soirée
là on va faire beaucoup plus sûrement je
l'espère c'est l'objectif c'est
l'objectif voilà alors avec vous avec
l'association skyden si aussi une
vingtaine d'associations c'est à dire
que les longs aussi grandit autour de
cette soirée une soirée caritative on
l'a dit oui il y a neuf associations de
danse autour de nous et d'autres
associations qui sont d'autres
partenaires notamment le Lion's Club
pour la première fois la Ferme du Manet
qui est vraiment partenaire cette
fois-ci les autres fois elle nous
accueillir mais là les partenaires ce
qui change quand même beaucoup les
choses c'est pour ça que je pensais
qu'on aurait
un bénéfice beaucoup plus important
de la salle si je comprends bien ça
c'était déjà le cas parce que ça montre
c'est la municipalité de Montigny qui
est à la fois partenaire puisque c'est
grâce à elle mais il y a des frais
techniques etc et de là la ferme du
manage a fait un gros effort objectif
caritatif savon tout un événement festif
aussi ceux qui tient oui oui c'est un
événement qui fait Steve qui est basé
autour de la danse et puis cette année
on rajoute aussi de la musique du chant
et
on fait tourner beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnes il y a beaucoup de choses au
programme beaucoup de d'ateliers de la
soirée se déroule avec des sous forme
d'ateliers d'une vingtaine de minutes
toujours 30 minutes 30 minutes cette
fois-ci
où l'on va proposer une découverte de
différents styles de danse d'initiation
auxquelles vous pouvez tous venir la
danse indienne la bachata de la danse du
hip-hop tout le monde peut venir c'est à
dire que c'est pas seulement aux initiés
à la danse confirmer au danseur confirmé
c'est pour tout le monde c'est vraiment
ouvert à tout le monde et vraiment tout
le monde accueilli et les plus jeunes et
les plus anciens et c'est vraiment une
initiation alors ensuite après sur scène
vous avez aussi des démonstrations de
danse fait par des gens un peu plus
professionnels ou des équipes qui sont
montées à travers les associations et
qu'ils vont qui vont vous présenter des
choses et qui vous proposeront aussi
ensuite de répéter ce qu'ils vous ont
montré auparavant sur la scène à côté de
cela il y a des pistes de danse aussi
vous pouvez être un petit peu c'est un
peu sous forme de dance club et c'est ça
sur le tir le disait il y a différents
types de danse en plus qui sont mises à
l'honneur les danses pratiquées au sein
des associations mais aussi des danses
du monde
des danses donc des associations de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a
Bollywood il y a de la danse africaine
la phobie tu as du hip-hop et bien sûr
il y a plus deux associations qui
présentent du hip-hop l'une ce sera
d'ailleurs des adultes jeune adulte et
moins jeune et l'autre ça sera beaucoup
plus des ados donc ça sera un peu
différent et c'est intéressant de voir
tout ça
du country et du square dense surtout
aussi c'est toutes les époques puisqu'il
y a aussi
le temps les vases qui proposent des
danses avant 1914 donc il y en aura
vraiment pour tous les goûts avec des
ateliers aussi des ateliers et il y a
plus de 17 ateliers de 30 minutes donc
on peut pas assister à tous il y a 5
plages d'ateliers il y a des choses à 1h
du matin mais exactement il faut choisir
il faut choisir et puis quelques petites
surprises voilà et du coup les bénéfices
de cette soirée sont reversés au
Téléthon on peut faire aussi des dons
directement au téléphone on peut faire
des dons sur place aussi c'est très
important de le dire effectivement pour
la première fois on est organisateur de
l'événement donc on aura une urne
Téléthon et vous pourrez directement
faire des dons qui sont des fiscalisés
on le rappelle important si vous voulez
donner 200 euros c'est c'est 600 euros
enfin vous pouvez donner 600 euros et ça
ne vaut le coup coûte que 200 euros par
exemple donc on peut diviser par 10 ou
question pratique pour terminer on peut
venir directement est-ce qu'il faut
prendre une fausse s'inscrire avant ce
qui est bien c'est de s'inscrire soit
d'aller sur le site de solidence soit
sur lui de Skydance on y accède
directement et voilà on prend son billet
éloasso ça coûte 10 euros et il y a un
food truck pour la première fois aussi
enfin il y a plein de première fois
comme première fois pour cette cinquième
pour édition de solidence la soirée
caritative au profit du Téléthon qui se
déroule donc ce samedi à la ferme du
manège Montigny-le-Bretonneux 19h à 1h
du matin peut-être un appel à passer au
téléspectateurs venez nombreux oui venez
nombreux on s'amuse bien merci à vous
deux d'être venu en parler en tout cas
sur ce plateau et on poursuit cette page
culture avec cette exposition qui est
visible depuis le 18 octobre au château
de Versailles Louis XV passion d'un roi
métal honneur sera fidèle au château de
Versailles qui a régné pendant près de
50 ans l'exposition est visible jusqu'au
19 février on regarde le sujet sujet de
Céline Charles
[Musique]
qui était vraiment Louis XV un passionné
de sciences et de botanique un roi
discret un homme ou multiple conquêtes
pour fêter le tri centenaire de son
couronnement le château de Versailles
mais à l'honneur ce roi méconnu arrière
petit-fils du roi soleil
on l'amenait jusqu'à être appelé le roi
bien-aimé mais à la fin de son règne la
situation n'était plus les mêmes les
dernières années de sa vie ont été
beaucoup plus sombres Madame de
Pompadour l'extraordinaire pendule de
passement les souper au cabinet le roi
et la chasse l'exposition propose une
approche plus intimiste de Louis XV où
l'exercice du pouvoir était passé au
profit de sa personnalité cette
expression est consacrée est divisée en
trois parties principales une partie
consacrée à l'enfance l'éducation
l'entourage familial ou non familial de
Louis une deuxième partie plutôt
consacrée aux passions du roi et une
troisième partie plutôt consacrée aux
arts autour de Louis XV la partie qui
est consacrée à la chasse dans cette
exposition se traduit avec l'accrochage
de tableaux qui ont tous figuré dans les
appartements locales les tableaux de la
salle à manger choisi de gigantesques
tableau de bacheliers représentant la
chasse au lieu de la chasse à l'ours 400
œuvres provenant de différents musées
francs également de collection
posées certaines n'ont jamais été
présentées auparavant on peut également
y découvrir le style rocaille appelé
style Louis XV typique de l'époque comme
cette commode du roi cette commode qui
est un meuble mythique qui est un
chef-d'oeuvre de la rocaille qui a été
dessiné par ou imaginer par deux frères
endomanie les frères slot c'est un
meuble qui était dans une chambre royale
et on s'aperçoit que c'est un meuble
avec deux portes latérales de vantaux
latéraux et manifestement cette
ventolatéraux servait au barbier à
mettre le matériel nécessaire pour la
toilette du roi le matin le parcours
offre également la possibilité de
visiter quelques-uns des lieux les plus
les emblématiques du château
l'appartement de la marquise de
Pompadour les appartements du dauphin ou
encore la chambre de madame du Barry
dernière favorite du roi une exposition
à découvrir jusqu'au 19 février 2023
au menu culturel vous avez également un
rendez-vous ce dimanche avec la
cinquième édition du Salon du livre
d'Élancourt organisé par les Amis du
passé d'Élancourt en soutien avec le
soutien de la ville et de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est 10h à 18h du côté de la
Commanderie Bernard Delattre est avec
nous pour parler de cet événement je le
rappelle vous êtes coordinateur et de ce
salon du livre et on commençait tout à
l'heure à parler de ce thème de cette
année littérature et cinéma la
passerelle a été souvent faite entre les
deux univers
dernièrement il y a eu le film sur le La
Comédie humaine avec janelli tout ça où
j'étais figurant dedans
enfin ça se retrouve mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup de thématiques entre
littérature beaucoup de romans ont été
source de films mais là avec une dresse
c'est l'inverse qui est président de
donneur puisque elle a d'abord fait le
film pas d'amour sans amour en
1993 avec Patrick Chesnais
Gérard Darmon Martin Lamotte et le
Suisse Bideau et donc à partir de ce
film elle a fait le roman après elle est
devenue romancier d'un univers à l'autre
revenir aussi de la littérature au
cinéma de la du cinéma
de donneur cette année c'était quelques
uns de ses films pourquoi la choisir
elle justement parce que le bel exemple
et on a aussi Pascal petit qui a fait
beaucoup de films à une époque de
Téléfilm et qui vient de sortir son
autobiographie aussi elle sera là aussi
on a Thierry de Carbonnière qui a joué
dans Plus Belle La Vie qui a fait du
cinéma qui réalisateur aussi et voilà on
a pas mal de gens on a aussi
Nelson Monfort très grand journée
sportifs de sport mais il est très doué
et on a aussi clair le LUC Didier
Derouin qui s'occupait longtemps du
cinéma de Rambouillet qui a fermé
malheureusement il s'occupait aussi d'un
cinéma à Gif et je suis plus en Ess
ouais le principe on le voit donc on
vient c'est le même principe que dans
les autres salons du livre on peut
rencontrer les auteurs se faire
dédicacité il y a trois enfants s'il y
aura des conférences avec Evelyne dress
avec Claire Le Luc et Didier Derouin sur
le la gestion d'un cinéma de quartier de
ville et la troisième conférence c'est
c'est on aurait dû avoir genre sa russe
mais
des Charlots s'il a fait plein de films
aussi mais il est malade malheureusement
et il est remplacé
environ
55 60 et c'est un événement qui grandit
en année vous arrivez facilement à
boucler le programme à chaque fois
il y a énormément d'auteurs on n'a pas
de mal à trouver 50 60 hauteur on
pourrait en avoir 10200
c'est dramatique c'est comme si vous
avez un banquet où il y a 30 places et
vous avez 80 personnes qui demandent
c'est des choix drastiques et c'est pas
facile on essaie de faire tourner à
chaque fois les gens ils rouspètent
pourquoi lui pourquoi pas moi c'est
c'est pas ça là c'est pas facile et
alors justement donc c'est dimanche mais
il y a l'avant-première si on peut dire
voilà on est dans le thème du cinéma
donc l'avant-première c'est c'est
peut-être le terme le mieux choisi la
veille a une soirée autour du cinéma
justement avec Evelyne dress elle va
animer deux films le premier film c'est
la tendresse bordel un film un peu culte
avec avec Bernard Giraudeau elle jouait
vague dans un jour il fallait les gens
de mon âge se rappelle de suivre c'était
trop marrant quoi c'est un très drôle
avec des scènes dingue et mine de rien
c'était quand même les débuts du
féminisme et de dénoncer le machisme
avec humour c'était moins violente
maintenant mais c'était dénoncé quand
même de façon rigolote et après le film
pas d'amour sans amour à 20h30 le fameux
film que Évelyne dress a réalisé produit
et là dedans elle rejoue une Eva près de
30 ans après elle attendait ce bordel
elle joue à la 4 partenaires Gérard
Darmon Jean-Luc Bideau Patrick Chesnais
et Christian lamentais drôle
samedi soir avant le salon du livre qui
est dimanche Gabriel une question
peut-être oui j'en profite vous par du
féminisme je crois que Évelyne dresse
est très engagée dans le féminisme c'est
c'est d'actualité finalement de proposer
un film
elle a dénoncé ça regardez rien que la
photo là où elle avait 4 bonhommes on
voit bien que c'est elle qui choisit
quoi mais dans le film pour créer des
spectateurs s'en rendent compte dans les
films il y a des trucs très drôles et
des scènes que je peux pas décrire ou la
façon dont elle envoie balader des des
machistes tout ça c'est mais cette façon
drôle mais les mecs ils sont bien
démontés quand même quoi donc le
programme on l'a compris des rencontres
avec les auteurs des conférences
également vous en avez parlé sur les
infos purement pratique l'entrée est
libre bien sûr de 18 de 10h à 18h
non-stop et donc il y a pas seulement le
livre cinéma il y a aussi les polars
avec les éditions La Joigny un fort
rayon jeunesse avec la librairie Le Pavé
dans la main pas on a un mois de Noël
donc il y aura plein de je pense c'est
un beau cadeau un livre pour enfant
dédicacé par l'auteur et souvent ils
font des dessins il y aura aussi
roman jeunesse des romans la poésie la
poésie sera présente et que Jacques
hostile par exemple qui de Montigny sont
recueil de poèmes est excellent j'ai lu
Suzy maltrait de Rambouillet Roland nado
qui va revenir spécialement l'ancien
président du scan de l'époque qui est
devenu poète et voilà il y aura ces
communes librairies quoi ouverte avec un
thème précis cette année littérature et
cinéma mais aussi
à l'honneur merci beaucoup Bernard
Delattre et je le rappelle un
rendez-vous c'est dimanche la cinquième
édition du Salon du livre d'Élancourt et
c'est à la Commanderie de 10h à 18h
Francis Perrin lui sera ce vendredi 25
novembre à 20h30 au Mureaux pour une
représentation de L'École des femmes
pièces de Molière qui le mettent en
scène et dans laquelle il joue le rôle
d'Arnold l'une des particularités de
cette mise en scène c'est qu'on retrouve
dans les principaux rôles sa femme
gerent qui joue sa servante Georgette sa
fille Clarisse qui joue Agnès et son
fils Louis qui joue Horace le jeune
garçon et puis on va qui parviendra à
sortir la jeune Agnès des griffes
d'Arnolphe Louis a été diagnostiqué
autiste quand il avait trois ans dans
l'émission vyb Francis Perrin explique à
Patrice carous comment son fils s'est
préparé pour jouer cette pièce et la
joie qu'il ressent sur scène je vois
partager par sa famille et par le public
regarde un extrait c'est ça qui est
merveilleux
et puis c'est son plaisir c'est
de jouer de d'être en scène cette
énergie alors on se demandait bon
on savait qu'il allait qu'il allait y
arriver on a beaucoup travaillé mais
comme avec les autres comédiens
d'ailleurs c'est mais on se disait
est-ce que ça va être régulier parce
qu'on a on joue je vous dis près de 100
présentations là on arrive à 95
représentations et ben il a toujours la
même énergie la même régularité le même
professionnalisme
que d'autres camps et surtout cette joie
d'être en scène et ce plaisir de
partager et avec le public
c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est frappant
d'ailleurs c'est c'est en effet oui pour
lui ça doit être une joie immense
évidemment
pour vous pour Gersende et pour sa sœur
Clarisse c'est aussi une loi immense que
vous partagez tous quoi c'est
complètement oui oui c'est c'est un
étonnement de chaque instant
aussi mais en même temps c'est ce qui
fait aussi que notre famille
a une complicité depuis depuis très très
très longtemps et qu'elle se recent en
scène et que les spectateurs sentent
cette joie d'être ensemble aussi et
cette admiration enfin qu'on a envers
lui parce qu'on est tout de même
oui oui on est à la fois fier heureux et
puis surtout très très heureux de le
voir de le voir dans cette joie de joie
immense de jouer
émission vypr retrouvé en intégralité
sur TV 78 l'application tv78 et aussi
sur notre site Internet TV 78.com
[Musique]